one of our favorite guests loved hanging
with him and all of his friends in
Kansas City for the big slick raising
millions of dollars for the local
Children's Hospital there and Rob
riggles ski master Academy is streaming
free only on Sony crackle all eight
episodes available right now good to see
you good to see you we just saw a nice
clip with you and Brian Urlacher yes the
very how did how did you cast Brian
Urlacher here and say is the guy who
runs the rival canoe camp across from
the ski master academy run walk me
through the process
yeah well Brian and I actually became
friends on a USO tour back in 2014 and
it was interesting tour by the way it
was me
Brian Urlacher and Megan Markel who has
gone on to great royalty fame yes and I
don't know if you knew that or not she
actually married a royal she did
probably didn't get much play she
cheated we're married most kids that
know doc Kusaka should be so lucky
yeah yeah so anyway we bonded there and
had a great time but anyway I needed a
nemesis and I couldn't think of a better
name assist than Brian Urlacher cuz he's
this big sweet kind of teddy bear type
guy and I needed someone that I could
unjustifiably be rude to and mean and
with his size and proportion that just
have him be sweet and nice yes and me
constantly ragging him I just always
loved that little yapping dog at the big
dog yeah kind of comedy so I threw him
in there well you know you're no wee man
yourself sir I mean what Urlacher when
you meet him yes he just he just keeps
going yes he's much bigger than you
would think he is a big man he's a big
you and quick which is you're not
supposed to be big and fast right God
only does that to a couple of us right
us yes sir nobody does you and me and
early and Urlacher are the only ones who
really get it so when you met her
lacquer he was bald right he didn't have
the hair right no he did not
is he different to you now that he's got
here Rob I mean how has he changed I'll
be honest he does walk a little taller
he seems a little more confident I know
it's bothering you though
there's Brockman and I Brockman and I
have had a problem with its like in look
you're you know you understand you don't
leave a good man behind never okay and
Brockman and I we feel we're good men of
the ball Brotherhood
yep and he left us but that's what it is
it's the Brotherhood
it's the BB it's the ball brother and
maybe it is that he that's where this is
okay okay - Rob I get it no but I get it
it's all about us you feel like somehow
he he Benedict Arnold yeah little in a
way no no I have a question for you is
like is like folks like Travis Kelce
upset you didn't you know stay within
the family the the Chiefs family to cast
anybody in the ski master I haven't
received any pushback yet from trav on
that one but season one I like to flow
it out you know and and look Travis
Kelce I think if he keeps going he'll be
a Hall of Famer too but this year I was
only casting Hall of Famers
you've got a very high high bar high
standards so for season two of Rob
riggles ski master Academy which can be
of season one streamed right now on Sony
crackle how about Andy Reid don't you
think he no I mean he he doesn't look
like a guy that you think has comic
chops no I would not issue at all I know
but don't you think you know him on a
him on a jet ski I think is gold forget
about that yes I mean that would be
comedy gold that alone I don't have to
give him dialogue don't you think just
watch him out in the middle of the lake
wrestling a jet ski might be might be
worth it okay I'm writing this down
mentally you're - yeah I'm actually
gonna put this like this is a possible
script or yes he could even open his own
camp also across the lake a rival a
rival camp
what is it the those paddle boards just
seeing him on yeah just you know seeing
if he can get across the lake that would
again anybody gold rich and they keep
the dialogue down to a minimum so it's
really good I think by the way is that a
new fantasy team name
what is Andy Reid's paddle board Andy
Reid's paddle board you're in a fantasy
league rob riggle tonight right now
you're drafting this evening are you
know
I have a big draft going down with my
league the Hollywood phonies collection
of real jerks I want to protect their
anonymity okay but Matt Walsh Bears fan
yeah from Corddry rob corddry is here
Friday okay we got Jerry O'Connell Ron
Livingston Adam pally Scott Armstrong
where's then where is the trial Shearer
where's the draft being held Oh your
house it's done electronically we don't
we're not doing a we're not taking over
a tavern which we should
dude we should you're just all sitting
in your office yeah wherever the hell
you smack talk via a keyboard but you
need I contact when you do smack talk
right not at the sting what I mean you
know it's message boards are so 19 we
try I think we do try we've tried in the
years past to to converge and then you
know attendance hadn't been that great
so okay I think that's why we've been
doing electron what's your draft
position were you drafting real simple
all Chiefs that's your strategy but
what's your what draft choice do you
have
well I don't even know yet you don't
know I don't know see you ready you're
you're you're ready that you're just
gonna show up I'm gonna show our own
virtual footballs out yes and what's the
Nate what's your team name do you even
have that duck butter well we need to
know I can't explain it but I think a
lot of the guys out there know I'm
talking about it do it just step into
that one Brockman you could just go to
urban dictionary and just check when I
was again because I realize the the
Chiefs yeah my team yes back in the day
used to be somewhere over Dwayne Bowe ah
I like that somewhere overdoing bow
that's good now you got to just say
you're over Tyreke he'll now that we're
entering like Behrman zone right now
Oh Rob Riggle on Twitter and then you're
getting set for NFL on Fox for this
Sunday yes yeah we it it begins and so
it begins
you're seven of
Wow NFL pregame damn man yeah I know
this would be my seventh season having a
blast I love it
I can't get enough so okay and they they
they're not getting rid of me yet not
yet I can tell they want to think
Bradshaw wants in a special pass a
master Academy oh I would love to bring
those guys out come on now
come on stray Howie it seems like but
you remember Terry Terry in the 80s and
1970s he was a custom music singer oh
yeah that's an Hooper who can forget his
parents and Hooper the ski master
Academy's got that 70 eighties feel to
her does AAB it does you know what I
mean oh I would love to bring him in on
a stallion on a white stallion and maybe
one this hasn't quite been broken so
he's having a hard time controlling it
throughout the scene I mean that would
be I kind of want to see that now I got
a budget for it no not at all but that's
okay I've got a lot of friends I can
call a lot of favors you know what I had
to do for this one so Rob Riggle you are
I think the biggest Kansas fan I know
okay thank you you well you're welcome
and also I'm sorry because this past
weekend I'm sorry I'm not familiar yeah
yeah you're not familiar with this boy I
didn't college I just assumed we won
what was the score of the Kansas Jayhawk
competitions it's Jayhawks football
competition e26 223 lost two nickels I'm
sorry
nickels nickels is a person nickels yes
we have found out you you you don't know
who Nichols is I've never heard of
nickel okay would you like to know who
Nichols is I'm not sure I do
okay you ready here we go this is the
this is who is it Nicholls State with
home with Nichols state Nichols College
Nichols state Nichols state I know all
the states in the Union sir there was no
state called Nichols okay here we go
Frances reading to Lou Nichols
was an American attorney politician
judge and a brigadier general in the
Confederate States Army during the
American Civil War killed Lord a
two-term governor of the state of
Louisiana
from 1876 to 1880 and then from 1888 to
1892 sort of the Grover Cleveland of the
Statehouse of Louisiana holy smokes
okay it's in Thibodaux so this is a
louisiana institution of higher learning
would you like to know more about know
how to make it hold on a second
nichols joined the Confederate Army
participated in the First Battle of Bull
Run and in the Shenandoah Valley
campaign in Virginia where he lost his
left arm hold on in the Battle of
Chancellorsville in 1863 a shell ripped
off his left foot let's got a rough go
over is it too soon is it still even too
soon
okay so let's break it down yeah
the Jayhawks football program is on the
on the rise I know it's hard to believe
after a stumble at home on the home
opener against Nichols who by the way
had no battle at Richmond lost an eye as
well had no I know arm and no left foot
correct but still managed to put
together apparently a quality football
team because they'd be just an overtime
on the home opener yeah I know I heard I
heard all about it
and if you want to hear me say it out
loud yeah yeah it cuts like a knife and
I'm not happy about it but doesn't make
it anyone know we say a bad word about
my Jayhawks all I'm assuming there was
some terrible calls it's mine I'm a
two-minute officiating there weren't
there were in Michigan's lost under
Notre Dame see you get a terrible call
terrible calls I have no doubt and I'm
sure that we were going to bounce back
next week with vigor and Verve who do
they play next week central at Central
Michigan there you go you got to travel
to chip Chipmunks applause but the
chipmunks know the Chippewas the
Chippewa right the second the Chippewas
okay who do you hear from when Kansas
loses everybody everybody that I know
all my friends I have a Michigan friend
who loves
remind me every loss the wins indoors
not much like nickels we don't have a
much of a leg to stand on if you will I
know I said to again is it too stony I
will say stone Street has been pretty
gracious and just ain't got a scare
didn't can't you stay yes they did they
got barely one you know home opener
that's right or at least their season
open played out Dakota yeah the two of
you yeah but everybody I know pretty
much calls to give me the business on
that okay it's by the way enjoy it laugh
it up fuzzball cuz its it's gonna when
we turn it around I'm coming for you
who's the fuzzball all everybody
everybody who's I'm texting yeah okay
so Rob riggles ski master Academy how
did you come up with this one Rob
honestly it was it started as a joke
people would ask me what are you doing
what are you doing these days and I
would get tired of giving people my
resume so I told them I was opening a
jet ski Academy and then I'd walk out of
the room and on the drive home I'd be
like you know what if I did open a jet
ski Academy that'd be pretty fun and
then I started thinking about who the
cadets would be who would be on the
staff who would be my instructors what
the lake would look like who the lake
commissioner would be and so I just
started filling out this world and then
I pitched it to some comedy buddies of
mine been at Weber and Chris PZ and
Sarah Tiana and some other folks
understand we started pitching this
stuff around and we put together a pitch
and Sony crackle in their wisdom
infinite wisdom infinite wisdom said
this makes sense to us let's go have
some fun and we did and we made a
ridiculous comedy that is everything I
hoped it would be honestly a lot of
times when you make a TV show it goes
through this filter and gets watered
down and and you know too many
executives weigh in on it and it doesn't
turn out to be what he started it to be
yes we got no interference like Sony
crackle was on board from the get-go and
they let us run amok why I think that
you you you could easily state that a
good management team when they hear the
idea of a ski master Academy
should just let you run with it yeah I
mean like there's no there are no notes
thank you that they could possibly yeah
but just let you go with it yes yes
there and they're called what they say
like notes they gave us we're like could
you maybe use like a bottle liquor
instead of the bag of cocaine and I
would say mmm the cocaine plays there
you go you're right it does and that's
that and that Sal we worked it out I
mean these guys are fantastic magic
again they lent us they really let us do
I haven't been involved in many projects
where you feel like your voice actually
got out there yeah and I feel like it
got it get got out there that out there
Cheech Marin
I mean Christopher McDonald I mean she's
McGavin you may know him better as she
better friggin McGavin we had David
Arquette we had jamie-lynn Sigler Tim
Meadows you know plays late Commissioner
who's one of my favorite all-time the
lake commission yeah which is was that
based on Roger Goodell Commissioner I'll
let you watch and decide for yourself
okay yeah just want to make sure yeah
that we're all good I love having you
here man before I let you go yeah big
slick kc.org you're always the website
people go to and donate to Children's
Mercy Hospital in Kansas City for which
you raised how much money this year 2.2
million dollars in one weekend and you
and your whole team here much credit
goes to you because y'all came out no
you came out and you set up shop and you
did your old show from the K when you've
been a wonderful supporter of this
charity and this event and we're very
grateful to you and everybody here so
thank you 10 years next year coming up
on 10 I know it's hard to believe but
yeah 10 years mm-hmm yeah and we've done
we've done I think some good for for
some very deserving people and it's
again big slick kc.org for an incredible
cause and then there's the ski master
academy don't miss the ski master
academy it's gonna be a lot of fun also
i'm gonna be in night school at the end
of this month what you have a Kevin Hart
Tiffany Haddish movie dude it's gonna be
a good one that's fun fantastic but but
definitely enjoy look guys you can
beat the price on Sony crackle it's a
hundred percent off it's free it's free
all you gotta do is just watch that's
they're all waiting for you all eight
episodes of glory waiting for you
and Urlacher and early the t-shirt
tucked into shorts and a belt and hi
Hank
hi knee socks I'm telling you you're
gonna see him like you've never seen him
before
fantastic good to see you rob so good to
see you man I'm back anytime at Rob
Riggle on Twitter again check out Rob
Riggle ski master Academy free right now
on Sony crackle the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience